long before he was the handsome
anti-hero in multiple blockbuster movies
he was a cackling super villain in a
whole bunch of old comics
and before that of course he was an
actual god in mythology
here's the untold truth of marvel's loki
like thor and odin loki originated in
norse mythology where they were all
major pre-christian deities of the
scandinavian people
whereas most norse gods were big burly
guys with long beards loki was always
portrayed as
lithe androgynous and sneaky although he
was the child of frost giants he was
associated with fire and the color
red like fire he could not be easily
contained and never kept to just one
shape
he and odin king of the gods were blood
brothers which made him basically a
member of the family no matter how much
trouble he caused
and as the god of mischief he caused no
end of trouble
he also produced monstrous children who
had their own roles to play in the
mythology
he was the father of hell the
half-withered goddess of the underworld
and of fenrir the giant wolf who bit the
hand off of the god
tyr having once taken the form of a mare
he was the mother of odin's eight-legged
horse
sleipnir as a prank loki once cut all of
the hair off of thor's wife
sif when he got in trouble for it he
made amends by giving sif new hair spun
of gold and also commissioning the
dwarves to forge
thor's famous hammer mjolnir when loki
proved too
troublesome odin bound him under the
earth where a serpent constantly drips
poison on his face
he'll be released with the coming of
ragnarok the norse apocalypse in which
all the gods and monsters will fight to
the death
loki's first appearance in marvel comics
was in journey into mystery number 85
published in 1962. this version was
created by jack kirby and stan lee who
had introduced thor only two issues
earlier
once thor had become a superhero it only
made sense to bring in loki as a super
villain
stan lee freely drew what he wanted from
the norse myths while kirby created a
visual language for marvel's asgard
one that made these super gods look
unlike any norse people who'd ever lived
while retaining some basic iconography
the new loki was still slimmer than thor
and odin but
now he had black hair and dressed in
green and gold whereas thor's helmet had
wings
loki's had large horns instead of odin's
blood brother marvel loki was his
adopted son
making him thor's brother and thus a
more equal adversary
he relied less on shape-shifting than
his mythical counterpart but made up for
it with impressive skills at sorcery
loki became thor's recurring arch enemy
and perhaps even more importantly he was
the very first villain who faced the
avengers
in fact he accidentally brought the team
together attempting to mess with thor
from a distance while imprisoned in
asgard in avengers number one
loki manipulated the hulk to make people
think he was on a rampage
that got not only thor involved but also
iron man ant-man and the wasp
when the four heroes realized loki was
the true culprit they teamed up with the
hulk to battle loki
afterwards they decided to stay together
as a team using their combined powers to
protect the world from threats too big
for just one hero
avengers
assemble super villain or not loki was
still thor's brother
that made their relationship much more
complex than other heroes in their arch
enemies
with loki there's some part of him that
loves thor and knows thor loves him back
just as they both love their father odin
on top of that
as more of a mischievous sorcerer than
an evil world conqueror
loki was just too interesting to stay
entirely a villain forever
so in time there were stories where he
teamed up with thor to face greater
threats
the most notable example was in the
1980s during the acclaimed thor run by
writer artist
walt simonson and the culmination of a
long foreshadowed plot
the fire giant sirter was attacking
asgard with an army of the dead
and threatening all the realms beyond
odin and his two sons
stormed into battle together each with a
battle cry and that revealed their
priorities in resisting surter
during the siege crossover loki
sacrificed himself and died
he was then reincarnated as an
adolescent boy
far more pure of heart than his older
counterpart kid loki had his own series
of adventures in a new volume of
journey into mystery at the end of that
story kid loki's body was taken over by
a more amoral version of the character
from his previous incarnation
although he retained the kid loki
identity kid loki went on to found a new
version of the young avengers featuring
the kate bishop version of hawkeye as
well as
wiccan hulking marvel boy and america
chavez
over the course of that series the other
young heroes gradually came to trust
this young god of mischief
even as loki himself struggled with
whether or not he was worthy of that
trust
late in young avengers kid loki is
magically aged up to around college age
he remained younger than he'd previously
been while becoming enough of an adult
to interact with thor and other adult
characters without being treated like a
child
after the end of young avengers loki got
his own comic titled
loki agent of asgard the idea behind the
title was that loki no longer villainous
but
still amoral was perfectly suited to
take on secret and sometimes ethically
suspect missions for the rulers of
asgard like a one god black ops team
it was a perfect premise for the
character and led to some well-loved
stories
meanwhile the marvel cinematic universe
was making loki more popular than he'd
ever been
with tons of people who'd never read a
marvel comic becoming big fans of the
character
a huge part of that popularity has to be
attributed to the work of tom hiddleston
the handsome english actor who was cast
in the role most of hiddleston's
previous acting work was on british
television and he was largely unknown in
the united states
that changed with the release of thor in
2011 in which hiddleston's loki was the
primary antagonist
at the beginning of the movie loki is
presented as an ally to his brother thor
accompanying the thunder god and his
friends on an ill-fated trip to
jotenheim
home of the frost giants things soon
break down however when thor is exiled
to earth and loki learns he's actually
of the frost giant race himself
as odin enters a mystical slumber loki
plots to take over asgard
to do that he has to remove thor from
the line of succession even if it means
killing him
although he was the villain of the piece
fans enjoyed his complicated morality as
much as his handsome face
justice loki was responsible for the
founding of the original avengers in the
comics
so too was hiddleston's version in
2012's the avengers
in this version loki is wielding a mind
controlling staff and is working in
tandem with an alien race in an attempt
to conquer the earth
to stop him shield brings together thor
iron man captain america the hulk black
widow and
hawkeye once again loki's actions lead
to the formation of earth's greatest
super team
to his regret you are all of you beneath
me
i am a god you dull creature and i will
not be
bullied by
2013's thor the dark world finds loki
imprisoned in asgard following the
events of the avengers
when dark elves invade and kill frika
mother of thor and adoptive mother of
loki
thor releases loki to help defeat the
elves while this sequel is frequently
criticized audiences did get something
they'd been wanting a less evil loki
in fact that's what tom hiddleston
wanted as well in a 2013 interview with
total film magazine hiddleston explained
when i met alan taylor director of dark
world he asked me how i thought i could
do loki again without repeating myself
and i remembered talking with kevin
feige when we were on the avengers
promotional tour i said okay you've seen
thor and loki be antagonistic for two
films now
it would be amazing to see them fight
side by side loki's duplicity inevitably
emerges at the film's end of course
the god of mischief appears to die
heroically in battle with the dark elves
but he later reveals himself
as alive and masquerading as odin by
taking his father's form
loki has achieved his ambition to rule
asgard
after appearing in marvel movies for
three years in a row loki had a
four-year break before turning back up
in 2017's thor ragnarok
upon returning to asgard thor finds his
brother still impersonating odin
the two go in search of the real odin
who has returned to norway the land
where he once was worshipped to die
upon his death the death goddess hela is
freed from an ancient imprisonment
she effortlessly destroys thor's hammer
and then sends thor and loki careening
into endless space
loki finds himself on the planet sakar
and ingratiates himself to its ruler the
hedonistic
grandmaster thor soon arrives as well
and is forced to fight as a slave in the
gladiatorial arena
where his first opponent is the hulk
soon thor and
loki team up with bruce banner and a
long-lost asgardian valkyrie to escape
zakhar and return to asgard to face
hella in ragnarok loki's still not
exactly trustworthy but he's not a
villain at all anymore
and ultimately proves himself a worthy
ally to his brother as the two escape
the destruction of asgard with most of
the population in a huge
ship that wouldn't worry brother i feel
like everything's gonna work out fine
this new status quo however would be
sadly short-lived
avengers infinity war released in 2018
is the climax of the marvel meta story
that had been building since the first
movie
it's fitting therefore that it begins
with thanos invading the asgardian ship
and killing
loki the original avengers villain dies
a hero at the hands of the ultimate
villain who was secretly using loki
during the invasion of earth and the
avengers
at this point thanos is gathering the
infinity stones as part of his mission
to wipe out half of all life in the
universe and none of the asgardians are
powerful enough to stop him from gaining
the tesseract
the infinity stone that was at the
center of that plot in avengers
hiddleston's loki had evolved so far by
this point that it was sad for basically
everyone not just the loki mega fans to
see him strangled to death by thanos
he came so close to being a hero in his
own right and maybe there at the end he
was one
when he turned up next however it was as
the villain he'd once been
thanos wins at the end of infinity war
so in 2019's avengers end game
the surviving avengers have to go back
in time to recover the infinity stones
from various points in history
before they were acquired by thanos as
they explained before doing so each time
they change the past their actions
create
an alternate timeline where things went
differently one of their time travel
destinations is the aftermath of the
invasion in the first avengers when loki
had been defeated and taken into custody
during the confusion loki is able to get
his hands on the tesseract once more and
use it to escape to parts unknown
what this means of course is that
there's a loki out there in the marvel
multiverse again
despite his death at thanos's hand in
the main timeline
but what it also means is that the loki
who now exists is one who'd never fought
alongside thor against the dark elves or
help save the other asgardians from
hella
this loki comes directly from a time
when he was very much a villain
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one